the startling case of a man who lived
for hours after he was declared dead
he's set to go to trial in April Tammi
Cleveland says her husband Michael kept
moving and breathing after she was told
he died she says hospital staff ignored
her pleas for help until a coroner
alerted them saying dead people don't
move the doctor and the hospital say
they did nothing wrong and the delay did
not cause his ultimate death on Friday a
New York judge allowed the lawsuit to
proceed but reportedly trimmed
Cleveland's claims and denied her
request for punitive damages she spoke
to our doctor Tara Narula one week ago
today about what she saw the night her
husband seemingly came back to life
Tara good morning good morning Gary yes
it is Michael Cleveland was a 46 year
old married father with no known history
of heart problems until he went into
cardiac arrest one night in 2014 that's
one of my favorite pictures as usual he
always says something silly he's always
making me laugh Tammy Cleveland's happy
memories cannot erase the nightmare of
her husband's final hours it must have
been like for him to listen to the
people that I should be able to trust
trying to convince me and my family that
he's dead and he's laying there alive
Michael Cleveland collapsed while
shopping for dinner in this Buffalo area
Supermarket medics performed CPR and
shocked his heart then rushed him to
nearby de Graaff Memorial Hospital less
than an hour later Michael was
pronounced dead by ER dr. Gregory Perry
when you first walked in the room what
was your first observation that Michael
wasn't dead he was following me with his
ice it wasn't just an involuntary thing
I mean he looked right at me you saw his
eyes tracking you you saw his body
moving what else did you witness that
made you think he might still be alive
he was you know trying to hug me
he brought his legs up on the gurney
knees bent flat-footed I mean he was
breathing she claims that over the next
several hours her husband continued
showing signs of life and his family
repeatedly asked medical staff to check
him did you see his chest no
yes just moving up and down while dr.
Perry entered the room twice the lawsuit
says on those first visits he did not
perform a physical exam that could
confirm life or death
he didn't never put a hand on him and he
never put a stethoscope on him did he
hook him up to a monitor or no dkg no he
and Michael had that tube down his
throat what was his explanation for why
Michael was still moving he said that
Michael is only 46 years old he said
that he's got a lot of life out of his
to expell out of his body a coroner came
to remove the body according to his
pretrial testimony he was startled by
what he saw and called out for nurses to
get dr. Perry dead people don't move he
said he needs to go in there and check
his pulse two hours and 40 minutes after
Michael had been pronounced dead dr.
Perry examined him and found a pulse he
was alive medical tests showed Michael
had suffered a heart attack he was
transferred to Buffalo General Medical
Center doctors there performed a
procedure to open a blocked artery but
it was too late at 10:48 the next
morning Michael Cleveland died dr. Perry
and DeGraaf Memorial Hospital would not
comment citing the pending lawsuit de
Graaff Memorial has said in legal
filings that had followed all medical
standards and required procedures dr.
Perry's seen here at his 2010 medical
school graduation said in his deposition
that he did check for a pulse in those
first two visits and found no signs of
life but on the third visit Michael
Cleveland's condition was quote vastly
different the doctor at Buffalo General
who opened the blocked artery stated in
his deposition that Michael Cleveland
was too sick and he would never have
survived even without the delay at de
Graaff CBS News legal analyst Ricky
Clemens says the effect of that delay
will be a critical issue for the jury
you're going to have the defense experts
who say they did everything they could
and then he was pronounced dead and no
matter even if that was in error and we
know it was an error because he became
alive that that would have made no
difference he was going to die anyway
plaintiffs experts are going to say of
course there was a chance that he would
have survived
he was only 46 years old do you carry
guilt that you were supposed to be
Michael's voice and you couldn't do
enough for her medical field at the time
yeah I feel horrible it's hard for any
doctor who wasn't there to comment on
this particular case but that being said
in general when someone has a heart
attack due to a blocked artery every
minute counts because the heart muscle
dies very quickly without oxygen and you
can't help but feel for mrs. Cleveland
you can feel her pain and what you just
said every minute every second counts at
a time like this so what can families do
when the hospital step isn't listening
to them when you say look I know what I
see here that's one of the big messages
and I know that's what Tammy felt very
strongly about that you don't have to
feel helpless or powerless even though
you're in this very vulnerable state as
a patient or a family member there is a
ladder or a chain of command that you
can escalate things to you can go to the
attending physician in charge of the
unit you're in whether that's the ER or
the floor
there's always an administrator on-call
a chief medical officer an executive
director and you should feel that you
can escalate things if you're not being
heard yeah you should never stand down
when you can see something that's right
that apparently seemed she saw him
following her with his eyes and she did
a really interesting story Tara
interesting and ravishing chattering yes
thank you